I have Rob this is the fourth video in a
series of videos looking at stuff
sparring if you haven't seen the
previous videos I suggest watching them
first I'll post links in the description
below in this part we're going to be
sparring with Ratan stapes same as in
the other videos I'll let it all play
through and then I'll break it down at
the end in slow motion so we start with
me on the left wearing black shoes
Rogers on the right wearing white shoes
[Music]
let's start with this clip where Raj
comes from the thrusting I parry he then
follows up with an attack down my left
side the parry comes up a lot when
training and Aikido and the round staff
is the closest material out of all three
in trying to replicate the oak joke
which would normally be training with
with it being light and having a bit of
flex it's way more forgiving than oak in
combination with protection you can see
here rad strikes my hand and we carry on
without injury with a no clap that just
wouldn't happen so in this next part no
one runs a strike however I wanted to
point out a few things that are worth
considering go first strike and hit the
end part of Rogers stuff which is all in
one hand then ricochets and hits the
opposite end if this was a solid oak jaw
I think it'd be very difficult to block
with this part the stuff the round stuff
has a lot of flex not as much as the
plastic and Joel but with it being
extremely light it seems to bounce a lot
which reduces the amount of power that
can be delivered for sparring it's
obviously good but as a downside it
changes out the staff can be used for
those that train without Jose you'll
know the amount of power that can be
generated and if you parry one-handed
you like to get your staff knocked out
your hand
in this clip that several exchanges will
burn those spikes are landed there are
three instances where Raj goes for 100
strikes and I block walking bucket and
now I had several opportunities to
counter as soon as was changed his
position I go first right to his knee
however I'm still out of range there's
definitely a better feeling wrong
contact when striking we ran I think it
creates more awareness with the foam and
plastic I'd normally try things out
however here I've been a bit more
cautious and wait for an opening when
the strikes came in I could have
countered with a one-hand to strike down
Rogers left side as he's left open here
obviously iron sights a wonderful thing
and this is another reason why it's
useful to film yourself sparring as you
can reflect on what you've done and how
you can improve
[Music]
so here Raj goes for my leg and misses
and I follow up with the thrust which is
parried and then I finish off his right
to Rajas elbow if you can see we're both
maintaining a distance from each other
and when one attacks the other one moves
back however when my strike lands on Raj
it's because I've also moved in and
slightly off line at the same time as
him coming forward this is something
that's often trained in Aikido so if
you've seen the second part in this
series you will have shooting a
combination of movements similar to that
in this clip we'll go through explain it
again so you can check out if you
haven't done so already
I'll also be covering some common themes
in the next part in this series similar
to the clip I played at the beginning
you can see Raj striking out my left
side I can't make out whether he got my
hand on just the stuff but just wanted
to pause the clip so you can see the
flex on the stuff it may seem like quite
a lot but I think it's just the right
amount of flex to take out some of the
impact but not too much that the stuff
here was floppy and dead for those that
are familiar with Aikido the twelve
sabore is a 100 strike at a tatami uchi
this is featured a lot throughout the
sparring this is normally done
right-handed however I wanted to point
out that we practice everything on both
sides which provides a lot more options
and opens up a lot more possibilities
this last part shows number 20 from the
31 count car it appears a few times
where I drop down and go first right to
Rogers knee so after my thrust Raj comes
back and I leave my guards slightly down
giving him an opening its ought to see
but I feint to go high and get the
timing right as I dropped as he starts
to raise also this time I'm in distance
and I'm out of the way of Raja strike
so with regards to the run stuff the
flexibility is just right in my opinion
and with a smooth hard surface the
handling is good and so is the feedback
when you strike another staff it creates
enough caution and awareness about being
here I'll wave protection and control
the risk of injuries minimal the
downside is the stuff feels really light
which does compromise technique however
that's the trade-off before 1 into spar
safely the next video will be the last
in the series I'll be giving a song of
all three types of stuff we've tested
and I'll also be looking at Aikido
movements that seem to be coming up a
lot inspiring anyway I hope you enjoyed
the video if you did please like
subscribe and share until next time take
care